in the last video we talked about how
every atom really wants to have eight
let me write that down
eight electrons in its outermost shell
that this is kind of the most stable
configuration that an electron could
have and given this fact that's been
determined just by observing the world
really we can start to figure out what's
likely to happen in different groups of
the periodic table and where a group of
a periodic table is just a column of the
periodic table like this group right
here and actually I'll start with this
group because it's a it's got a special
name this group right here is called the
noble gases and what's common when you
go down a group in the periodic table
what's common about a column in the
periodic table in the last video we saw
that every element in a column has the
same number of valence electrons or it
has the same number of electrons in its
outermost shell and we figured out what
that was this column right here which we
learned where the alkali metals this has
one electron its outermost shell and I
made that one caveat that hydrogen isn't
necessarily considered an alkali metal
one it doesn't it's usually not in metal
form and it doesn't want to give away
electrons as much as other metals do
when people talk about metal like
characteristics of an element they're
really talking about how likely it is to
give away electrons but we'll talk about
other characteristics of a metal
especially the ones the way that we kind
of perceive metals is being shiny and
maybe they conduct electricity and see
how that plays out in the periodic table
but anyway back to what I was talking
about this column right here this is
called the alkaline earth metals so this
is alkaline earth alkaline earth these
have these all have to these all have
two atoms in its outermost shell so
remember everyone wants to get to eight
if these guys wanted to get to eight by
adding electrons they have a long way to
go this way we'd have to add seven
electrons they would have to add six
electrons and who are they going to take
it from because these guys don't want to
give away their electrons they're so
close to getting to eight so it's much
easier when you're on the left-hand side
the periodic table to give away
electrons in fact when you only have one
to give away that especially in the case
of elements other than hydrogen when you
only have one to give away it really
wants to do that and because of that
these elements right here
they're very seldom found in their
elemental state when I say elemental
state means there's nothing but lithium
there there's nothing but there's
nothing but sodium there there's nothing
but potassium there they're very likely
if you find this it's probably it's
already reacted with something probably
with something on this side of the
periodic table because this wants to
give away something really bad this
wants to take something really bad so
the reaction will probably happen these
are still reactive the alkaline earth
metals are still reactive but not as
reactive as the alkali metals and that's
because these guys are really close to
getting to the stable the magic eight
number these guys are a little bit
further away so it takes a little bit
more I guess you could say a little bit
more a little bit more of a push for
them to give away to this guy only has
to give these guys only have to give
away one and then we learned that the
this has to in its outermost shell and
then all of these elements which are
called the transition metals as you add
electrons they're just back filling the
previous shells d subshell
right so their outermost shell still has
to it still has those you know if this
is the fourth period these are all of
these all of these elements outermost
shell has has four s2 and the end these
elements are just back filling their 3d
sub orbital or their 3d subshell or so
these are twos so these all have two
outermost electrons so these all of
these like the alkaline earth metals
they need to lose two electrons in order
to quote-unquote be happy and the way I
think about this and this is really just
a way and yeah I mean it may be it bears
out in physical reality is that these
guys have kind of a deep bench of
electrons that if they are able to shed
shed some of these valence electrons so
you know if iron if I write iron as
my right iron has two valence electrons
like that even if they shed these
electrons they kind of have a reserve of
electrons in the d subshell
and the d subshell for the previous
shell so if it's shed it's for s two
electrons it still has all those three D
electrons that have a high energy state
that can maybe kind of replace them and
I'm you know I'll use everything in
quotation marks because these are just
ways for me to visualize things and the
reason why I make that point is because
metals like to just they're just very
giving with their with their electrons
and these guys these guys react I mean
it's just hey take my electron these
guys say take these two electrons and
these guys they start to say as
especially as you fill the D sub cells
look you know I got these two electrons
and not only do I have those two
electrons but I have more electrons
where well almost where that came from I
have some in reserve and my D and what
happens in these transition metals and
it especially happens in the metals so
these are the metals right here and
these don't follow just a group but this
is the metals this color right here is
that they have so many electrons to hand
off not only do they have these extra
there but they filled their d subshell
that they can kind of especially when
they're in elemental form and when I say
elemental form these means that you know
you just have a big block of aluminum
aluminum hasn't hasn't uh hasn't reacted
with anything like oxygen it's just a
bunch of aluminum right and when you
have a bunch of aluminum what happens is
you have these metallic bonds where all
of the aluminum atoms say you know I
have all these extra I have definitely
well in the case of aluminum I have
three electrons in my outermost shell
but I have this all this all of these
kind of backfilled electrons in my D sub
orbital I'm just going to share them
with the other aluminum atom so you
create the C of aluminum atoms and
they're attracted to each other or you
get the C of aluminum electrons so you
know you bunch of have a bunch of
electrons sitting in between sitting in
between the atoms and since the atoms
kind of donated these electrons they're
attracted to them right so you know the
the actual atoms so this would be an
aluminum plus and maybe it would have
donated three electrons but this isn't
you know I'm not being exact here I
don't want to just give you the sense of
how things were
and that's why metals conduct really
well because could electricity is just a
bunch of electrons moving and in order
to have electrons moving you have to
have surplus electrons laying around so
if the elements right around this area
really good conductors in fact silver
silver is the best conductor silver
right here is the best conductor on the
planet and the reason why that's not
used for our wiring and copper is is
because copper is easier to find than
silver but silver is the best conductor
and the way I think about it is is that
these when you once you filled an
orbital that orbital becomes somewhat
stable so all of these guys have filled
their D orbital while these guys their
de overall is not fill so this have a
lot of surplus electrons that are really
good for conduction now that's just an
intuition there's not you know I haven't
done the experiment to prove that but
it'll give you a sense of why things
conduct and all of that so these are the
transition metals these are the actual
these are actually considered the metals
but the reason why these are considered
the transition metals is because they're
filling the d-block but you know
transition metals kind of sound like not
as good as a metal but when I you know I
think of metals iron is kind of the
first metal I always think of I
definitely think of silver and copper
and gold as metals so to call them
transition metals is a little not fair I
don't really consider aluminum more of a
metal then then let's say iron is but in
chemistry classification world
aluminum is more of a metal these
elements right here and I know I dropped
off from kind of the group notion but
let me just actually write the valence
electrons so these will have three
valence electrons four five six seven so
these all have three electrons in its
outermost shell it still seems easier
for them to give them away than to take
them but maybe now in certain cases you
know there could it could be especially
in the case of let's say boron there
could be a situation where it maybe
could gain five electrons well that
seems hard you know that it's much
easier to give away three and that's why
a lot of the quote-unquote official
metals show up in this category and as
you can see as you go down the periodic
table you can kind of have metals that
have more and more valence electrons so
for you know this
this let's say lead it's willing it's
it's still a metal even though it has
four valence electrons and that's
because it's got ins it's the atom is so
big that that it's radius is so large
that the outermost shell is so far away
from the nucleus that those electrons
are easy to take off so for example as
you go down carbon those electrons are
very close to the nucleus so they're
very hard to take off so carbon would
probably more likely gain electrons from
somebody else to get to eight while
these guys these guys valence electrons
are so far away from the nucleus that
they're most lot more likely to kind of
want to get rid of them to get to eight
and get back to an electron
configuration let's let's say xenon and
you go and then these guys are the
nonmetals right they're likely to
probably gain electrons in most
reactions and then this yellow category
that I said was highly reactive highly
reactive and especially highly reactive
with the alkali metals over here these
are called halogens and you've probably
heard the word before halogen lamps
that's no that's no I guess there's no
that's no mistake there to call them
halogen lamps that's not a random choice
of words you know maybe I'll do a video
on halogen lamps in the future and then
finally we're at the noble gases and
what's interesting about the noble gases
well they have eight electrons in their
outermost shell right except for helium
helium has two right helium's electron
configuration helium's electron
confirmation is 1s2 but all of these
other guys this guy's electron
configuration is 1s2
is neon 1s2 2s2 2p6 so he has eight
electrons in his outermost shell so he's
happy argon same thing the outermost
shell
well the outermost shell will look like
3s2 3p6 Krypton will have its outermost
shell will be 3s2 3p6 it'll also have
some 3d electrons is it back filled back
here but all of these have eight in this
outermost shell so they're happy they
have no incentive to react they're kind
of like hey all of you other elements
just you know you guys can do all that
crazy reactions that you got to do but
we're happy and we don't want to give or
take electrons
and because of that these guys are
highly highly unreactive very very
unreactive and you know back in the day
when they used to make these kind of
what Zeppelin's these these big blimps
you know the the Hindenburg is a famous
example they used hydrogen and obviously
hydrogen is a pretty reactive substance
it's actually very combustible and
that's why it blows up very fast and
that's why now clowns or you know
children's balloon manufacturers they
instead would prefer to use helium
because helium is a noble gas it's very
unreactive and it's very unlikely to to
explode and a child's birthday party but
anyway I think I'm done now with this
video and in the next video we'll talk a
little bit more about trends across the
periodic table